I have video for you today of Donald
Trump devolving into an incoherence sort
of stream-of-consciousness rant after
CNN reporter Katelyn Collins pressed him
about how hey you said Mexico was going
to pay for the wall they're clearly not
have you failed on that and I want to
really set this up properly for you
before we look at the video
Trump said during his 2016 presidential
campaign time and again I'm gonna build
a wall on the us-mexico border and
Mexico's going to pay for it now it was
never happening only the least informed
from fost could possibly have believed
that Mexico was going to pay for the
wall and over time it became more and
more clear that yeah Mexico is not going
to pay for this wall they were never
going to pay for the wall so Trump has
started to look for funding in other
places he wants funding from you right
the taxpayer to pay for that wall he
threatened to shut down government over
funding for the wall then he actually
shut down government over funding for
the wall a government that is still shut
down so Caitlin Collins did a totally
reasonable thing which is say hey you
know what about that Mexico is gonna pay
for the wall thing and Trump of course
immediately becomes condescending
towards her and then it gets hilarious
when Trump goes into this incoherent
rant and I'll explain what Trump is
trying to talk about here but failing to
actually explain after we watch it again
Trump trying to use language to
communicate something of meaning failing
miserably it's hard to watch it's hard
to listen to but check it out and
remember the question is what about
Mexico paying for the wall Trump doesn't
answer he goes on a rant about concrete
and steel it's a long clip but stick
with it because what's important is he
talks for nearly three minutes and
doesn't answer the question you'll also
hear him sniffing a lot you ran your
campaign promising supporters that
Mexico is going to pay for the wall
you're always going to be made of
concrete
you just said earlier that the wall
could be made of steel and right now our
government is shut down over a demand
from your administration that the
American taxpayer pay for the wall so
how can you say you're not failing on
that promise to your supporters a very
nice question so beautifully asked even
though just answered it let me just
excuse me you ready are you ready I just
told you that we just made a trade deal
and we will take in billions and
billions of does far more than the cost
of the world of Wallace peanuts compared
to what the value of this trade deal is
to the United States as far as concrete
I said I was going to build a wall I
never said I'm gonna build a concrete I
said I've got to build a wall just so
you know cuz I know you're not into the
construction business you don't
understand something we now have a great
steel business that's rebuilt in the
United States Steel is stronger than
concrete if I build this wall or fence
or anything that Democrats need to call
it because I'm not into names I'm into
production I'm into something that works
if I build a steel wall rather than a
concrete wall it will actually be
stronger than a concrete steel is
stronger than concrete okay okay so you
can check it out listen if I build a
wall and the wall is made out of steel
instead of concrete I think people will
like that and here's the other good
thing I'll have it done by the United
States Steel Corporation by companies in
our country that are now powerful great
companies again and they become powerful
over the last two years because of me
and because of our trade policies so if
I have a steel wall or you could call it
a steel fence but it'll be more powerful
than any of the concrete walls that
we're talking about it's possible that
it will look better and one of the
things I think you have seen this that's
very important for us very very
important in speaking of Border Patrol
ice and actually local law enforcement
and even military they want to be able
to see through it you can't really see
through a concrete wall they want to be
able to see who's on the other side of
the wall because if they're here and you
have about a 12 inch concrete wall and
you have people on the other side but
you can't see what's over there it's
very dangerous they want to be able to
see through the wall a see-through wall
made out of steel is far stronger than a
concrete wall so I'm very happy with it
I think I think I'm not sure but I think
that's what the demo
Kratts prefer and if it can get them
there I'm okay it actually will be a
more powerful wall and it will be a more
beautiful wall than having a concrete
wall so it's a new trade deal mr.
president Jeff Jeff so no answer there
about in 2 minutes and 54 seconds about
Mexico paying for the wall Caitlin
Collins trying to follow up about that
but the trade deal lie and the
microphone given to somebody else so let
me explain that trade deal thing Trump
is started floating this harebrained
explanation that even if Mexico doesn't
give us the money for the wall or pay
for the wall to be built that because of
Trump's new trade deal they sort of are
paying for it this is the idea and I've
tried to explain it before and concisely
the idea is if the wall costs 25 billion
and the modified trade deal with Mexico
leaves an extra 25 billion to the United
States that this is sort of like Mexico
paid for it now this is dumb for many
reasons one being that money from trade
deals doesn't become available as cash
for a wall you still have to separately
fund the wall the political decision has
to be made to fund the wall and it's a
pretty big stretch to say that that
would even count remotely as Mexico
paying for it but the more important
thing is if you do a deal that changes
the trade balance by 25 billion that's
not 25 billion to the government that
they can use to buy stuff or build a
wall that's 25 billion in trade balance
for American companies the government
doesn't get the 25 billion Pat and this
idea has gone completely off the rails
and there's one more layer here too
which is if Trump thinks that Mexico is
paying for the wall through the new
trade deals then why do the American
taxpayers have to pay for it why is he
shutting the government down over this
isn't Mexico paying for the wall under
this explanation yeah I mean I think
that it's almost like he's saying we
need formally the the money to be
authorized but then we're getting it
back or something I mean it's completely
incoherent and the fact that it took him
three minutes to not answer that
question effectively filibustering his
own press conference tells us that the
guy is standing on to call it shaky
ground would be an overstatement
ABB's
lutely meaningless ridiculous idea
repeating nonsense until the reporter
just gives up and the microphone is
handed to somebody else or the press
conference ends in this case just moving
on and talking to somebody else just
pathetic absolutely pathetic let's talk
about Donald Trump's commandeering of
American television to propagandize
about the border wall over which he shut
down the government last night
we will talk about the content of this
address I mentioned yesterday during a
livestream that I did covering this and
and also earlier on yesterday's show
that there are really kind of three
issues here number one is is there
actually an undocumented immigration
crisis I laid out the case yesterday for
why there is not secondly if there were
such an immigration crisis would the
wall that Donald Trump is proposing be
the solution to that crisis I explained
why it would not and then issue number
three layer number three was would a
presidential address of this type in
primetime on television be the right
place for overt political lobbying for
the policy that Donald Trump wants and I
also made the case that it was not and
the the speech in the end was nine
minutes long half just lies at a rate
that we maybe have not seen previously
during a Trump speech the other half
just anecdotal appeals to emotion and
I'm not gonna focus too too much on
those because I think our audience
mostly understands that you don't make
policy based on anecdotal appeals to
emotion but we should talk about the
lies that we're told because that
actually is important but the primary
takeaway is this address never should
have happened it was purely political it
was a lobbying speech I actually would
be okay with a presidential address in
primetime on all TV networks for
lobbying the public about a real
emergency or a crisis right we have a
climate change emergency on our planet
if we had a president say I'm going to
address the American people because of
the crisis that is climate change in
what we're doing to our planet that
would actually make sense because it's
real a real crisis could be we've got a
president who's an accused serial sex
assault er with at least one shy
accuser that is more of a crisis than
the crisis of undocumented immigrants
coming over the us-mexico border so
there are many ways in which I would
support a president saying I need to
address the nation tonight this is not
one of them and most of the lies that
Trump told were told up front I'll go
through a few of them I'm not gonna play
the nine minute thing because it's only
nine minutes and it's very easy to find
I'll focus just on analyzing the lies
that we're told Donald Trump called this
he sort of opened this thing yesterday
calling it a growing crisis and as I've
already outlined it's not a crisis at
all but it's definitely not growing
there's no evidence that this is a
growing problem border crossings are
lower and lower and lower each year
dating all the way back to the year 2000
there has been an increase in the last
few months but that's mostly asylum
seekers who are people going through the
correct legal process to ask for asylum
in the United States Donald Trump said
we don't have any way of returning
people to where they came from quickly
quickly is subjective but we do have a
mechanism for doing that however the
fact that Trump has shut down government
is actually what's slowing that process
down making it so that immigration
hearings have slowed down to an absolute
halt Trump arguing that we are really
hurt economically that this is a strain
on resources undocumented immigrants
that does not appear to be true
undocumented immigrants pay in to social
welfare programs from which they will
never get money back out
they are single-handedly holding on
their backs and shoulders multiple
industries which would collapse without
them and most importantly Donald Trump
made the case that economically
undocumented immigration is hurting the
United States because undocumented
immigrants drive wages down what is an
amazing ruse about that is that it's the
corporation's who want to pay lower
wages that are the ones benefiting from
that and it's an unbelievably a brazen
act of misplaced ire to be mad at the
people coming here to work for
better life than the corporations that
take advantage of them and choose to
hire undocumented immigrants without
being punished if we started enforcing
penalties on corporations that hire
undocumented immigrants you would solve
an overwhelming majority of the problem
if corporations weren't known to hire
undocumented immigrants then you
wouldn't have so many people getting
jobs and looking for jobs it would be a
problem that in great part would fix
itself then Trump talked about Americans
are dying from drugs that are coming
over the us-mexico border listen that
that is it's true that Americans are
dying from drugs but that's not coming
exclusively because of drugs coming over
the us-mexico border a lot of it is
marijuana first of all which nobody is
dying from and secondly according to the
DEA it's mostly being smuggled through
ports of entry not through the parts of
the border which would be blocked with
Trump's border wall ok understand that
most of the drugs coming into the United
States from Mexico are coming hidden and
smuggled in vehicles and on persons
through the actual legitimate
on-the-record ports of entry meaning a
wall wouldn't do anything about it
Donald Trump is saying that thousands of
Americans are being killed by
undocumented immigrants yearly I was not
able to find data that supports that
although I'm open to having my mind
changed Trump insisting that it's a
humanitarian crisis well just saying
that doesn't actually make it so and
then Trump's starting to move into the
appeal to emotion phase of his address
by saying women and children are the
biggest victims of undocumented
immigration that is true but women and
children are always the biggest victims
period all over the world from all sorts
of circumstances that doesn't justify a
wall between the u.s. and Mexico and it
doesn't prove that we have an
undocumented immigration crisis Donald
Trump deliberately conflated border
security and a 25 billion dollar wall or
35 billion dollar wall by the time it's
all said and done and what's really
important to understand
there is that it's untrue what Trump
said that Democrats aren't willing to
fund border security Democrats have
actually been willing to provide border
security funding not for the wall but
for technology and staffing in exchange
for reopening government and it's Mitch
McConnell and Donald Trump who have
refused to give any of those bills any
serious consideration it is untrue also
that everybody wanted a wall until Trump
was president and all of a sudden they
don't just because as a Democrat you
might have been willing years ago to
give Republicans some border fencing a
few miles of it in exchange for things
you wanted doesn't mean you're a
hypocrite because you now don't want a
twenty five thirty or thirty five
billion dollar wall across the entire
border so big picture you have a
government that is not shut down because
of Democrats Trump shut it down you have
a president who has failed to get what
he wants and is now throwing a literal
temper tantrum which caused him to
commandeer television networks for nine
minutes plus the lead-up coverage and
the Pelosi Schumer follow-up speech and
the analysis of it for several hours
across multiple networks and most
importantly there is no crisis and at
least for now Pat there's no indication
that this address has really moved the
needle for Donald Trump well we'll see I
think this comes across as effective
propaganda honestly because you have the
president on his own turf in the Oval
Office delivering a speech to the nation
calling the immigration situation a
crisis
calling it an emergency I think that's
going to be effective about you know
people just tuning in to their local
programming on CBS or NBC wanting to
watch their favorite show they may not
follow politics that closely they may
not stick around and hear the fact
checks here the response is given by
Pelosi closely and Schumer and you know
at this moment a majority or at least a
plurality of Americans blame Trump for
the shutdown I would not be surprised if
in the coming days we see that that's
flipped a little bit those numbers may
shift but you're already starting to see
even conservative political analysts say
it looks like Trump is going to fail and
he's going to
to relent and allow government to be
reopened we will talk a little bit more
about that but in the short-term
I don't see this helping Donald Trump it
came off is so not credible it came off
as so flaccid and beta in every way and
it also may have been an illegal use of
government resources for Trump's
campaign because minutes before the
speech the reelect Trump campaign sent
out an email asking for donations on the
basis of the immigration crisis and
previewing Trump's speech and if you
consider that sort of part of Trump's
campaign this was a political speech
used in this manner to help his campaign
and there are possible ways in that that
made have even violated campaign finance
law although I wouldn't expect him to be
held accountable for it
we will follow it and see what the
impact is there is a Jonathan Chait
article in New York magazine called
Trump literally did not understand what
a shutdown would do and it points out
that the shutdown continues were now
beyond two weeks and it's increasingly
clear that much like Donald Trump's
tariffs Donald Trump number one doesn't
understand what a shutdown actually is
and number two Donald Trump has no plan
for getting out of the shutdown because
now it's this situation where Democrats
just don't want to give him the money
for the wall period because they think
it's bad policy and Trump can't appear
to be the weak guy by accepting an end
to the shutdown without money for the
wall so we get to where we are now which
is a presidential address tonight
possibly to declare a national emergency
in justifying seizing money for that
wall so we end up with Trump saying he'd
be fine with months or years of a
shutdown if that's what it takes and
I've mentioned before that most of the
government isn't actually shut down
during the shutdown but some stuff
actually is shut down and shut down with
consequence so for example the
Washington Post is now reporting that
the Trump administration didn't realize
that during a government shutdown thirty
eight million Americans lose their food
stamps during a shutdown thousands of
tenants could be evicted without the
help that they would otherwise be able
to get from the Department of Housing
and Urban Development the Washington
Post explained
that the Trump administration is only
now realizing that this happens and now
they're trying to figure out without
ending the shutdown how can we help some
of these people who are been being hit
really hard by the effects of the
shutdown that we've decided to do
knowing Trump he likely was thinking
back to that short few days have shut
down in early 2018 and he thought not
much really happened so not much will
happen if this lasts weeks or months or
whatever except after a few days things
do actually start to go haywire people
going hungry not having food stamps
means they'll stop spending money if
their food stamp money at grocery stores
which is bad for the grocery stores
you've got the TSA working without pay
and starting to stage days where they
all call out sick this could spill over
an impact air travel which would [ __ ]
industries tax refunds will be in
jeopardy
once the filing window opens in February
and people can start filing their taxes
and expecting refunds what will happen
when people can't get their tax refunds
because government is shut down and just
like with the tariffs there was no
thinking before the shutdown about how
it would work there's also no thinking
about what the off-ramp is and I think
it's important to mention as well Mitch
McConnell has to be blamed it's not just
Trump unlike Trump Mitch McConnell does
know how government shutdowns work and
he's refusing to put up bills to a vote
to reopen government so this might not
accomplish anything either way Trump
might not care if McConnell wants to
reopen government but if we actually had
Republicans other than like the lone
couple of voices that are out there
saying we should reopen government if
Republicans and Democrats were pushing
for a reopening of government without
necessarily having to fund the wall it
maybe would serve as some pressure on
Donald Trump would a red state airport
shutting down be what it takes to get
government reopen Pat maybe but what's
increasingly clear is that he doesn't
even understand the consequences of his
actions and the only lens
through which he makes these decisions
is the political lens and the lens of
will I seem like the winner or the loser
in the end yeah
government shutdown is very serious
especially once against into weeks and
months into that time range and House
Democrats have tried to pass several
bills that would reopen parts of the
government like agriculture and the
Treasury and Justice Department the
stuff that has nothing to do with the
wall eek you can save that conversation
for later keep the debate going on
whether or not we should have a wall and
whether or not we should fund the
Department of Homeland Security until
that debates over with but Republicans
are having on a bit of course
Republicans having none of it and of
course the House Democrats within hours
of taking control of the house passing a
bill that would have reopened government
but McConnell's not hearing it Trump's
not hearing it so anyway Trump didn't
know what would happen during a shutdown
he probably still doesn't even really
get it and all that matters is will he
come away feeling that he won or will he
come away feeling that he lost nothing
else will matter not the people going
hungry not the fact that this could
[ __ ] air travel none of it makes a
difference to him it is truly idiocracy
2019 send me your thoughts how long will
this go on what will it take to end the
shutdown I'm on Twitter at D Pakman the
show is on twitter at david pakman show
and we have just a tremendous program
for you today okay the new Democratic
Congress has been sworn in Democrats
controlled the House Nancy Pelosi is
Speaker of the House and we're already
seeing Republicans triggered by
Democratic ideas and today we're going
to dig deep into first-term
congresswoman Alexandria acasio courts
has this idea it's not yet a proposal
just an idea of a 70 percent top
marginal tax rate on the super wealthy
specifically to take that money and fund
programs that are included in including
I guess I would say the green New Deal
which we've been hearing about and there
is so much to talk about here and there
are kind of three layers to this thing
okay first of all what's the proposal
how much tax on who and to pay for what
that's part one secondly what historical
data do we have about what happens when
you stick these high marginal tax
on the very wealthy and then number
three this is the most fun part do
Republicans not understand how marginal
tax rates work or are they deliberately
lying in order to confuse people about
them so stick with me until the end
because that's a sort of key part of
this entire thing so last night in an
interview with 60 minutes
Alexandria Castillo Cortez suggested
that maybe we should be looking at a top
marginal tax rate of around seventy
percent used to fund the green New Deal
and other proposals other programs and
to get rid of fossil fuel within twelve
years very ambitious goal I'm not gonna
play the clip from CBS because they've
been extra aggressive lately with what I
believe is fair use of their clips but I
don't want to put our YouTube channel at
risk so we are just going to read to you
a little bit about what she said about
the seventy percent top marginal tax
rate in her interview with Anderson
Cooper quote what is the problem with
trying to push our technological
capacities to the farthest extent
possible there's an element where yeah
people are going to have to start paying
their fair share in taxes I think that
it only has ever been radicals that have
changed this country yeah if that's what
radical means call me a radical so of
course this is a top marginal tax rate
meaning that you would see a
progressively higher tax as income goes
up the right like to say when it comes
to the sort of understanding the
underlying philosophies of taxation the
right likes to say that taxes should be
low on the rich because they create jobs
because the rich having more money
trickles down to the lower economy and
it raises all boats like a rising tide
this is called effectively supply-side
economics the left and people who
understand reality quite frankly
understand that there is a diminishing
marginal utility to dollars what that
means is if you have ten dollars to your
name an additional ten dollars doubles
your net worth that's huge if you have a
hundred dollars to your name
an additional $10 is useful but it's not
as useful to you as to the person who
only has $10 to begin with if you have a
million dollars $10 is nothing right its
interest on a savings account it's a
rounding error it's nothing and in the
same way the more money you have the
more likely you are to just let any
extra money that you obtain sit in a
savings account which is not stimulative
to the economy as much as giving the
money to poorer people would be who
would be more likely to spend the money
and inject it into the economy this is
called demand side economics at a
certain point the marginal utility of
another dollar is zero if you're Bill
Gates or Warren Buffett or Mark
Zuckerberg and you have billions of
dollars a one percentage point increase
in your taxes which leaves you with one
percentage point less money at the end
of the year it has zero impact on your
life maybe it's not literally zero but
it's point zero zero zero zero zero one
percent of each dollar actually impacts
your life and your financial decisions
in any way that is what a higher top
marginal tax rate capitalizes on that
for the very rich those additional
dollars do nothing for them but they
would do a lot for other people for the
economy for social programs etc so now
that we understand the idea let's look
at the data about the history of these
very high or higher top marginal tax
rates the u.s. used to have more tax
brackets and they used to have higher
tax brackets at the top so under Dwight
D Eisenhower as president the top tax
bracket was 91% this went down to 50%
under Reagan this went down to 38% after
the 1986 tax reform with more tax
brackets you can have different top
marginal tax rates for someone earning
five hundred thousand dollars a year a
million dollars a year ten million a
hundred million right now everybody
earning over five hundred and ten or so
thousand dollars a year pays thirty
seven percent
okay that's it the highest bracket
starts at five hundred and ten thousand
dollars in income and there's nothing
else above that it's thirty seven
percent all the way up so then we get to
what this policy and economic research
tell us the top marginal tax rate should
be well the question is what are you
trying to achieve the right is correct
when they say if you keep raising that
top tax rate at a certain point it will
stop people from working at all which
the government doesn't want because then
they make zero right so if you go to
high it actually reduces government
revenue what MIT research has found is
that a top marginal tax rate of seventy
three percent is the point at which the
government will maximize revenue by
taking advantage of that very high-end
for whom those additional dollars have
very little utility there's complex math
around it which we don't need to get
into but the point is a top marginal tax
rate of 70 percent as sort of floated by
Alexandria Acacio cortez if you set it
up with the correct brackets would be
something that raises a ton of money for
programs that would actually improve our
society so that is the the sort of
history of the tax brackets now lastly
some Republicans seem to not understand
that this is just a marginal tax rate
it's not the rate anybody pays on all
their income so as an example Republican
Congressman Steve Scalise tweeted over
the weekend about Alexandria Acacio
cortezes interview at 60 minutes where
she talked about this he said
Republicans let Americans keep more of
their own hard-earned money Democrats
take away 70% of your income and give it
to leftist fantasy programs no one wants
to take 70 percent of your money based
on a 70 percent top marginal tax rate
okay everybody pays the same rate on the
first five hundred and ten thousand
dollars that they earn you then put in
place higher rates for money earned
beyond that now I don't know if Steve
Scalise and other Republicans who are
saying this stuff
I don't know if they don't understand
how marginal tax rates work or if
they're deliberately playing dumb to
incite their followers but let's explain
it really really simply okay I put
together the 2019 actual tax brackets
with some hypothetical higher tax
brackets that would get us up to 70%
marginal tax okay so in reality right
now everybody pays 10% on income up to
ninety seven hundred dollars everybody
doesn't matter if you made a million or
ten million on your first ninety seven
hundred dollars you pay 10% likewise you
have rates of twelve twenty to twenty
four thirty to thirty five and thirty
seven percent on other income ranges so
if you make a hundred thousand dollars a
year you pay twenty two percent on
everything between forty and eighty five
thousand and then for what you earn
between it's exactly eighty four 201 and
a hundred thousand you pay twenty four
percent on your first eighty four
thousand dollars in income you pay the
same as everybody who makes less than
you and everybody who makes more than
you so the way that you could set up a
tax bracket system the way Alexandria
Castillo Cortez is proposing is that
maybe you pay thirty seven percent on
income between five hundred and ten
thousand and a million dollars and then
for income between one and ten million
you pay forty five percent for income
between 10 and 50 million you pay fifty
eight percent and then you pay 70
percent tax only on your income above
fifty million dollars a year so if you
earn 12 million dollars you pay that 58
percent rate only on what you make
between ten and twelve million dollars
again this is this is hypothetical this
is how marginal tax rates work this is
kind of like debt and deficit I can't
believe we're having this conversation
and that I have to explain to people
that the way the right is talking about
this stuff is either ignorant or I guess
we would say deliberately ignorant in
order to mislead you the idea
that someone is going to swoop in and
say you now give me 70% of all your
income that's not how marginal tax
brackets work my question to you do they
know this and they're playing dumb in
order to fire up their followers to say
AOC wants to take all your money or do
they not understand how marginal tax
rates work send me your thoughts send me
your thoughts on our Instagram page well
we will be posting a clip from this show
david pakman show on instagram follow me
David Pakman
quick break back after this Donald Trump
is going to be a commandeering all of
television or at least all of it that
has decided to go along with this very
obvious publicity stunt that he's doing
with the goal of fear-mongering about
the non-existent immigration crisis that
Trump has fabricated in order to justify
taking money potentially through the use
of national emergency declaration for
his us-mexico border wall over which he
has already shut down the government and
most media outlets are effectively
complicit in this and I'll talk about
that at how that works in a second from
the beginning of Trump's campaign he
fearmonger around immigration you'll
remember Mexico sending rapists and
criminals who bring drugs and crime we
will shut down Muslim immigration until
we can figure out what the hell is going
on we want people from Norway not from
[ __ ] whole countries like Haiti you can
say that now because it's quoting the
president we will build a wall and
Mexico will pay for it and then it
became clear that Mexico was never going
to pay so Trump instead demanded money
from you the taxpayer he couldn't get it
so he shut down the government which has
now gone on for more than two weeks and
now Donald Trump announced in a tweet
yesterday that he will address the
nation tonight on television saying
quote I am pleased to inform you isn't
he really that I will address the nation
capital a on address why we will never
know on the humanitarian and national
security crisis on our southern border
Tuesday night at 9:00 p.m. Eastern this
is propaganda this is a propaganda
speech the presidential Oval Office
evening
dress is or should be reserved for
actual crises or announcements of
consequence so I disagreed with going to
war with Iraq but I didn't disagree with
the use of the Oval Office nighttime
address for George W Bush to communicate
that on his orders bombings had started
in Iraq and a lead-up to our occupation
there when President Obama announced
that Osama bin Laden had been killed
although it wasn't at the Oval Office it
was an evening presidential address a
short one from the White House
so what Donald Trump is doing is he is
holding hostage the imagery of the big
presidential announcement on national
television to lie and to tell us that
this non-existent immigration crisis is
a crisis when it's not and that gets us
to the networks and the TV channels who
are complicit by covering it if they
don't live fact-check which I hope that
they will because he's going to lie is
ass off and this is where I'm thinking
of doing a livestream tonight during
which I will live back check Donald
Trump's predicted to be 8 minutes 8
minutes statement to the American people
the reality is of course that border
crossing attempts are at historic lows
and have been declining since before
Donald Trump came into office so the
idea that border crossings are down
merely because people are scared of
Trump that's not true we have a net
outflow of undocumented immigrants to
Mexico rather than a coming in from
Mexico undocumented immigrants commit
crimes at lower rates than american-born
citizens they pay into Social Welfare
programs that they're never going to get
benefits out of the agriculture and
restaurant industries just to name two
would be crippled without undocumented
immigrants and of course without
documented immigrants there is no crisis
but ABC and CBS and NBC and Fox Network
and Fox News and CNN and MSNBC they are
all going to be carrying the speech so
Donald Trump is successfully
commandeering television for a pet
project waste of money that he has
concocted
mind you because it's not just about
evaluating how networks will cover
tonight's address but it's also about
the hypocrisy that is there in their
decision to air it at all when President
Obama wanted to address the nation about
executive actions on immigration many
major networks said we're not going to
air it because it's quote overtly
political a fake border crisis possibly
culminating in Trump declaring a
national emergency in order to get money
for his wall is the most political way I
can imagine of dealing with the issue
and we will see Pat how these channels
deal with it I am I would rather them
not air it at all and later tell us what
was said and the truth or falsity of it
if they're going to do it they should
live fact-check I don't know if they
will for a few hours yesterday there was
a question over whether the network's
would air the speech and I was really
hoping that they would decide not to
because it's so overtly political and
cuz there's no real crisis at the border
but CBS decides to air and the other
networks followed suit I hope that at
least like CNN does that live
side-by-side fact-check thing they did a
similar thing with Sarah Huckabee
Sanders at a press conference at least
do that or give Pelosi Schumer and the
Democrats equal time to give their side
of things yeah and we'll talk about that
at the equal time idea on today's bonus
show and I'll mention right before
tweeting about the address which we were
told again will last eight minutes Trump
tweeted that the news media are crazed
lunatics and the enemy of the people and
now that same news media is doing
Trump's bidding so I may do a YouTube
livestream and I will alive fact check
if so my hope is that the address in the
history books will be seen as historians
as a turning point and a major political
mistake we'll see about that
I could not wait to get back into the
studio for today's show a partially
because we're off to the best new
members start of the year two hundred
and thirteen new members in the first
six days of January so far by far our
best start ever in a new year partially
I couldn't wait to get back in the
studio today because the YouTube channel
despite it being January which is
usually the worst month of the year is
already on
track to surpass 2018 by 30% even
without any more growth throughout the
year but it wasn't just self-serving
stuff I also couldn't wait to get back
into the studio today because it was a
huge news weekend starting with the news
that Robert molars from Prussia
investigation has been extended
potentially by up to six additional
months now why is this huge it's huge
because Trump and his defenders have
been telling us for more than a year now
that this thing is almost over for you
know forget for a second that they said
it would never get going right forget
for a second that they said no one would
ever be indicted no one would be
convicted no one would go to prison
those ships have already sailed over the
horizon but remember that starting last
Thanksgiving and that by that I mean
Thanksgiving 2017 okay not 2018 they
were saying Muller will be done by
Christmas 2017 Muller will be done by
January 2018 Muller will be done by
summer 2018
Thanksgiving 2018 Christmas 2018 and
then we were told right after the new
year 2019 molars going to be done well
we learned over the weekend that the
molar grand jury has been extended by a
period up to six months meaning the
investigation could go on up to six more
months if not longer now the actual
duration may vary depending on how much
more work there is to do and what I mean
by that is the grand jury was initially
18 months it's now been extended for up
to a six month period if Moeller just
needs another month then this would just
cover that additional month and then it
could end but whatever the time is this
has been extended and we should expect
many more indictments because it is the
extension of a grand jury indictments of
course so far include Michael Flynn and
Paul Manafort and Rick gates Constantine
kalanick kill him Nick I never know how
to pronounce his last name twelve
Russian military intelligence officers
13 Russians and three Russian companies
and remember that Michael Cohen's
indictment was actually for a separate
case not the Moller investigation
a we're still expecting indictments for
Roger stone and Jerome Corsi possibly
Donald Trump jr. and who knows at this
point how much further this will go and
it's really important to understand that
when this decision is made by a judge to
extend a grand jury beyond 18 months
they are looking at whether the
extension is in the interest of the
public and a judge looked at everything
and decided that despite the fact that
they've already had 18 months of this
grand jury it is indeed in the public
interest for the grand jury to be
extended and I am just shocked Pat that
Rudy Giuliani wasn't telling us the
truth when he said time and time again
that this thing was almost over yeah I
mean my rational mind says that this is
a good thing because it'll give Muller
more time and we can really get to the
bottom of what happened in 2016 and
potentially we'll see more indictments
because of it but on the other side I
kind of wanted to wrap up I want to see
what happened I want to hear what
Muller's findings are and I guess we'll
just have to be patient but by the time
six months is up that's gonna be two
full years of an investigation maybe the
country is getting tired of it well it's
not I mean here's the thing a politics
aside country getting tired and fatigued
aside this isn't shocking Watergate went
on for years this is a massive
undertaking you're looking at
criminality across multiple countries
across all levels of the organization
that was Donald Trump running for
president and you know every time that
we hear it's almost over we have to
remember wait a second how how would
anyone know that Moeller has been
running one of the tightest ships no
leaks
one of the most professionally run
investigations of its kind when we
actually learn what's going on it's
either because number one there are
court documents filed which we can read
or number two judges or other parties
confirm that something happened like
this grand jury extension which was
confirmed by the judge every single
supposedly cat trumpets have pushed out
about what's about to happen has fallen
flat because Moller is not taking any of
this he's not participating in this
news and gossip complex that so often
pervades these things when we found out
that one of his investigators was
sending inappropriately biased texts he
that individual was immediately
dismissed this is a Republican Special
Counsel who has run an airtight ship the
Trump is still want to defame and malign
him and I hope people are ready for 2019
because it's going to be an absolutely
massive year politically ok due to a
combination of stupidity and lack of
technical knowledge I guess I would say
Paul Manafort own lawyers have
completely blown the door open on
Russian collusion and we now have for
the first time thanks to Trump's
metaphors lawyers we have a Trump
campaign official confirming their
intent to collude with Russia on the
2016 election and they actually did so
this story is so incredible in the
ignorance and stupidity that it exposes
that it almost stretches credulity that
this has even happened but it happened
and I'm going to explain it to you today
you'll remember that Donald Trump's
former campaign manager Paul Manafort
has been convicted of all sorts of
crimes this happened last year now his
lawyers are saying that he is really not
doing well physically or psychologically
in prison and that is now being brought
to a court's attention but what you may
remember is that he has done a lot of
bad things not only that he commits a
bunch of crimes for which he was
convicted he got himself into more
trouble because after making a
cooperation agreement with Robert
Mulder's prosecutors he lied even more
which is a violation of the plea
agreement
his lawyers responded to that claim as
lawyers do but they messed up big time
because what man affords lawyers tried
to do was to put out a filing that
redacted four sections in their filing
and blacked them out and we're actually
putting up just one page of this filing
and people can see on screen right now
that the court filing has a bunch of
different lines that are blacked out
redacted so to speak except they didn't
do it correctly and even though in the
image we have up on the screen of
text is blacked out it looks redacted
this was done in such a way that if you
merely highlighted that blacked out text
copied it and then pasted it into
another document on your computer in
Microsoft Word or in WordPad or notepad
it pasted the full unredacted text of
what was covered up meant to be covered
up an incredible mistake and the real
blockbuster isn't the ignorant lawyers a
technically ignorant lawyers of Paul
Manafort
it's the content of what they tried to
redact because the redacted text says
that Manafort lied to Muller about
meeting Konstantin Killam Nick during
the 2016 campaign specifically to talk
about the quote Ukraine peace plan which
is code for the Trump administration's
softening on US policy towards Russia
for their actions in Ukraine Killam Nick
is connected to Russian intelligence so
this is a document not from Christopher
Steele not from Democratic operatives
this is a document from mana Ford's own
attorneys which confirms that the
campaign chairman of the Republican
nominee for president who eventually
became the president met with a Russian
intelligence agent I'm sorry
met with an individual connected to
Russian intelligence during the campaign
specifically to discuss what would
Republican policy be towards Russia and
Ukraine and to share polling data with
that same Russian individual the
document confirms collusion now remember
collusion in and of itself is not a
crime if Donald Trump knew that this was
going on that would be conspiracy and it
would potentially be obstruction of
justice depending on how Donald Trump
answered those questions in writing to
Robert Muller and there's a whole bunch
of possible crimes that are connected to
what is admitted here in this faulty
redaction of Paul manna Ford's document
remember how Russian actors ran those
targeted campaigns to try to influence
the election and one of the things they
did was target voters in specific parts
of the
it states in certain ways and in other
parts of the United States in other ways
Killam Nick is a business associate of
Russian oligarch Oleg Deripaska who has
been tied into influence campaigns and
by the way the Trump administration
decided to lift sanctions on Deripaska
he's connected to the guy manna fort was
meeting with so this has been blown wide
open pat by manna Ford's own lawyers
yeah these people are criminals but
they're not criminal masterminds and
contrary to popular belief they do not
have the best people working for them if
you want to get away with a crime as
serious as colluding with a foreign
power to win an election you have to be
smart about it you have to outsmart the
FBI and make sure that you cover your
tracks it doesn't really look like they
did that in this case yes and of course
collusion again not in and of itself a
crime but the entire conspiracy to do
this and the cover-up is what may
contain a whole bunch of different
criminality and this certainly makes
that case far far stronger Trump's
campaign manager while campaign manager
Paul Manafort provided to the Russians
during the campaign remember data that
they then used to target voters in
specific States to help Donald Trump
defeat Hillary Clinton the only
remaining link that we would be looking
for now
is that Trump knew this was going on
that would involve him in a criminal
conspiracy with Russia to seize the
presidency this didn't get the attention
it deserves because of surprise surprise
Trump's bogus border wall immigration
crisis prime time address last night
maybe by design maybe not who really
knows but every single box is being
checked slowly but surely
take any any one of these issues take
any of the allegations that have
surfaced over time and what at first is
a question mark
slowly but surely becomes a definitive
piece of knowledge about what it is that
took place every single box being
checked
imagine what we will know in six months
or by the end of twenty
19 absolutely stunning and unfortunately
again because of the timing of Trump's
border wall address last night this
should have gotten a lot more attention
and there's some complexity in it you
have to understand not only what was the
court filing but why is it relevant that
mana Ford admitted to having lied to
Muller about his meetings with Killam
Nick and how Killam Nick is related but
you need to understand a bunch of stuff
it's much more interesting to corporate
media to say Trump addressing the the
country about the border wall crisis way
easier probably better ratings for them
as well follow this story and other
stories from today's show on the David
Pakman show
Instagram page at David Pakman show and
while you're there follow me as well i'm
on instagram at david pakman